so we're going to think about in this
video is multiplying fractions so let's
say that we wanted to take two thirds
and we want to multiply it by four
what is this going to be equal to pause
this video and try to think about it on
your own
all right now let's work through this
together and to help us i will use a
number line and let's say that each of
these hash marks represent a third so
this is 0 this is one-third
two-thirds
three-thirds
four-thirds
five-thirds
six-thirds
seven-thirds eight-thirds and
nine-thirds
and so where is two-thirds times one
well two-thirds times one is just going
to be two-thirds we just take a jump of
two-thirds so that is times one if we
multiply by two or if we take two-thirds
times two that'll be two jumps so one
two thirds
two two thirds
three
two thirds and then four
two thirds so we just took four jumps of
two thirds each you could view that as
two-thirds
plus two-thirds
plus two-thirds
plus
two
thirds and where does that get us to it
got us to eight-thirds so notice
two-thirds times four is equal to
eight thirds now we could go the other
way we could look at a number line and
think about what are ways to represent
what the number line is showing us and
on khan academy we have some example
problems that do it that way so i
thought it would be good to do an
example like that and so let's label
this number line a little bit different
instead of each of these lines
representing a third let's say they
represent a half so zero
one half
two halves
three halves
four halves five halves
what did i write five six my brain is
going ahead five halves
six halves
seven halves
eight halves and nine halves and let's
say we were to see something
like this so if you were to just see
this representation
so i'm going to try to draw it like
this
so if you were to just see this
representation
what is that trying to represent what
what type of multiplication is that time
trying to represent
well you could view that as three halves
plus another three halves plus another
three halves because notice each of
these jumps are three one halves or
three halves so you could view this as
three halves plus three halves plus
three halves or another way of thinking
about it is this is three jumps of three
halves so you could also view this as
being the same thing as three times
three halves
and what are these equal to
well three halves plus three has plus
three halves or three times three halves
it gets you to
nine halves